[Música]
la justicia peruana ordenó 36 meses de
prisión preventiva contra el
expresidente Pedro Castillo el
mandatario ya se encuentra encarcelado
por 18 meses de manera preventiva a raíz
del fallido autogolpe de estado de
diciembre tenemos informe desde Lima
el presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel
López Obrador dijo que no permitirá
interferencia de gobiernos extranjeros
en su territorio por respuesta se da a
los llamados de republicanos a
intervenir militarmente contra los
cárteles mexicanos luego del secuestro
de cuatro ciudadanos estadounidenses y
la muerte de dos de ellos
en Chile una protesta estudiantil derivó
en enfrentamientos con la policía que
disparó cañones de agua para
dispersarlos se trata de la primera
movilización de estudiantes de este año
y en la que exigen mejores condiciones
en los centros educativos
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Perú la justicia de este país impuso 36
meses de prisión preventiva contra el
destituido presidente Pedro Castillo por
delitos de organización criminal y
corrupción recordemos que el ex
mandatario ya cumple 18 meses en prisión
preventiva por el fallido autogolpe de
estado de diciembre los detalles desde
Lima con nuestro corresponsal Francisco
Zacarías
el juez Juan Carlos chefle evaluó las
más de 300 pruebas en base a testimonios
y de Testigos y documentos que aportó la
fiscalía para sustentar los delitos que
habría cometido el expresidente Pedro
castillo y es que para la justicia
peruana Pedro Castillo sería el líder de
una organización criminal y que habría
cometido diversos delitos se señala como
manipulación de una licitación en la
empresa Nacional de petróleos para la
compra de combustible también se le
acusa del delito de tráfico de
influencias por haber nombrado personas
allegadas a su entorno como funcionarios
públicos y a su vez articular la
manipulación de licitaciones y el cobro
de coimas en los ministerios de
transportes y de viviendas la fiscalía
tiene un caso sólido con pruebas contra
Pedro castillo y va a ser muy difícil
que sus abogados puedan defender al ex
gobernante el Ministerio Público también
señala que posee pruebas que Pedro
Castillo ha tenido una conducta
dilatoria durante las investigaciones y
que ha pretendido evadir la
responsabilidad en realidad las cosas
van de mal en peor en Pedro Castillo y
su entorno porque el Ministerio Público
también alista un pedido de prisión
preventiva contra la ex primer ministra
Betsy Chávez y por si esto no fuese
suficiente la justicia peruana ha
programado para el próximo 15 de junio
un pedido de prisión preventiva por 36
meses contra la ex primera dama Lilia
paredes esposa de Pedro Castillo
nuevas tensiones entre México y Estados
Unidos esta vez por cuenta de la guerra
contra los cárteles de droga desde
Washington los legisladores republicanos
abogan por un proyecto que les permita
declarar a estos grupos como terroristas
y combatir los estén donde estén la
situación Por supuesto no ha caído bien
en territorio mexicano donde el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
dijo que no va a permitir la
intervención de gobiernos extranjeros
previamente consultamos a Carlos
matienzo politólogo y experto en
seguridad Internacional de la
Universidad de Colombia sobre Por qué el
gobierno de Joe biden se ha mostrado
resistente a Designar a los carteles
como terroristas
Sí bueno no es cualquier decisión
evidentemente no lo lleva totalmente
otro nivel este tipo de organizaciones y
las herramientas con las que cuentan
ambos estados para combatirlos pero más
allá de eso y lo que yo diría es que lo
preocupante en este caso es que México
no está haciendo su parte en combatir
estas organizaciones en específico este
gobierno el gobierno del presidente
López Obrador y eso está generando
tensiones con Estados Unidos nuestras
economías nuestras vidas están cada vez
más integradas entre Estados Unidos y
México y si no nosotros nos ponemos las
pilas en nuestro país en poner órdenes
nuestro territorio pueden pasar más
cosas como las de Matamoros están
llegando inversiones están llegando a
vivir esta estadounidenses a México y si
le siguen pasando tragedias como la de
Matamoros estas tensiones van a crecer
más y más me parece que la colaboración
entre ambos países es la clave porque es
un problema binacional Y si me lo
permites es un problema internacional el
del crimen organizado
en Venezuela el jefe de la delegación
del gobierno que se encuentra negociando
en México con los grupos de oposición
condicionó la a continuación de los
diálogos y dijo que el ejecutivo no
firmará ningún acuerdo hasta que sean
levantadas todas las sanciones contra el
país caribeño el funcionario también
reprochó que no se haya cumplido el
pacto que contempla la recuperación de
tres mil millones de dólares del Estado
venezolano que se encuentran bloqueados
en el extranjero
con toda responsabilidad
venezolana hasta que esté 100% libre de
sanciones hasta que no se levanten las
cinco medidas
unilaterales firmadas por Donald Trump
chile vivió a la primera marcha
estudiantil del año y que derivó en
enfrentamientos con las autoridades
nuestra corresponsal en Santiago
Patricia Luna nos contaba quienes eran
estos manifestantes y cuáles son sus
demandas
Pues el tradicional mochilazo volvió a
recorrer las calles de chile se trata de
uno de los movimientos que marca el
inicio en 2001 de la fuerza estudiantil
en el país y que se produce normalmente
en el mes de marzo cuando vuelven las
clases se vuelve a tomar la protesta y
se vuelve a tomar las calles son los
estudiantes secundarios los que los
últimos años han protagonizado las
manifestaciones y también el inicio de
las protestas sociales que por ejemplo
llevaron al estallido social y salen a
las calles a reclamar un poco lo que ha
reclamado siempre una mejor
infraestructura una educación libre
pública gratuita y de calidad también
una educación no sexista en este caso se
pide también la de renuncia del ministro
de Educación y otras tipo de demandas
como
una mayor Bono para programas de
alimentos debido al alza de los precios
que se vive en el país también mejoras
en la infraestructura
en Haití médico Sin fronteras se vio
obligada a cerrar su hospital ubicado en
la capital debido al incremento de la
violencia a través de un comunicado la
organización explicó que si bien la
instalación sanitaria no ha sido atacada
a los combates entre grupos rivales se
están llevando a cabo a sólo pocos
metros del edificio y que un gran número
de Balas Perdidas han llegado hasta allí
agregaron que son conscientes de que
este cierre tendrá un grave impacto en
los locales pero que sus integrantes no
pueden trabajar hasta que se garanticen
las condiciones de seguridad
mente las pandillas en marzo de 2017 41
jóvenes murieron calcinadas en Guatemala
en el centro que debía cuidarlas ya
pasaron seis años y la reparación Para
los familiares ha avanzado poco nuestros
corresponsales en Centroamérica Andrés
Suárez Jaramillo y Aurora bayut nos
cuentan la batalla de padres madres y
sobrevivientes por esclarecer las
circunstancias de la tragedia
41 globos para 41 niñas a quienes se les
arrebató la vida en la ciudad de
Guatemala se conmemora el sexto
aniversario del incendio de un hogar
para menores a cargo del Estado
Mira yo empecé a llorar porque yo pensé
que estaba quemada al ver a las demás
así porque yo pienso que
que en otros países con una niña que si
hubiera quemado así y hubieran
reaccionado Y por qué nuestro gobierno
nuestro estado nuestra Guatemala No no
ha dado respuestas realmente Mayra aidé
chután Urías que exigimos
después de seis años el juicio aplazado
12 veces no ha empezado
ha habido toda clase de estrategias de
parte de la defensa por ejemplo no
asistir a las audiencias reportarse
enfermos que por una u otra razón que el
tráfico
los padres Aún se mantienen de pie
reclamando justicia heridas salguero
madre de Keila una joven de 17 años que
perdió la vida en ese incendio aún no
asimila la pérdida de su hija como que
key la me los hubiera mandado a mí el
montón de rosas
para su mamá que no esté triste que ella
está conmigo siempre en el tiempo que
ocurrió el incendio las menores del
hogar seguro venían denunciando golpizas
abusos sexuales e incluso trata de
personas porque las niñas las abusaban
por eso es que ellos quieren que esto se
quede así no quieren que esto siga
verdad para que haya una justicia porque
saben que queremos llegar al punto de la
violencia que ellos estaban sufriendo
ahí adentro
varias familias de víctimas afirman ser
blanco de amenazas aún así han decidido
que no dejarán de alzar la voz para
conseguir justicia por la muerte de sus
hijas
hasta que ese informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]